cause the great in the powerful is it
great no is it powerful no is it okay
yes I'm not going to compare this film
to The Wizard of Oz I'm gonna review
this movie based on its own merits every
year someone saying it's an alright
movie that is exactly what this movie is
there's nothing really special about it
the prose there are some funny moments
here and there James Franco is a lot of
fun the monkey is [ __ ] awesome
there's great visual effects the cons
here we go all of the characters are
two-dimensional James Franco's
performance is the most layered but not
really he's funny he's charming but for
an actor with his capabilities he could
have brought more depth to the
performance Mila Kunis sucks Rachel
Weisz definitely did not bring her AGame
out of the three witches I enjoyed
watching the show Williams the most but
even she is pretty bland awesome parts
on this great adventure to take down the
Wicked Witch bears the problem I don't
give a [ __ ] why would I give a [ __ ] when
a his only motivation is based on greed
B we don't get to know any of the people
in Oz so what the [ __ ] do I care for
need them died James Franco has an
obvious but anticipated character art
but when he finally gets there it
doesn't seem like he's grown as much as
we're supposed to feel like he's grown
they constantly talk about scary witches
but it never feels like there's any real
sense of danger or a real threat at hand
this movie's just hell-bent on visual
effects don't get me wrong that are good
but when you're watching a movie with
characters you don't care strongly for
and when most of the attention to detail
goes more into the visual effects than
the story it's hard to say this film is
at least fun the phone has fun moments
but a lot of what should be excitement
or thrills feel surprisingly dull which
makes the visual effects not so
impressive anymore for a film that has a
huge spectacle it never got my heart
pumping I was calm throughout sometimes
I was even bored I never got excited I
never felt fear or worry for these
people something about the way this
movie was made had me thinking that Sam
Raimi did not have full control over the
direction of this movie because if he
had gone all Sam Raimi on us I'm sure we
would have gotten a much more
interesting plot but then again it's a
movie targeted for family and kids
so with all complaints aside
I can see how the target demographic
would enjoy this movie I don't mean that
in a way that family movie should get a
write-off if they're bad or something
all I'm saying is if I had to take my
future kid to a movie or being a kid and
watching this film I could see how it's
actually a lot of fun and there are some
good message isn't it and the final act
is actually pretty damn good so in a
weird way I gotta say Oz the great and
the powerful got it right alright guys
thanks for checking out the video
go ahead and tell me your points below
and if you liked the video go ahead and
like the video and if you want to see a
more in-depth review of positive rating
the powerful that I do with my buddy
Jerry go ahead and check out my show
reasons to see and if you must see more
upcoming reviews go ahead and subscribe
to my channel